Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is my intention to give a full account of the first war between Rome and Carthage, which was fought for the possession of Sicily. This is because it would be hard to think of a conflict which went on for longer, demanded more effort from both sides, or was prosecuted with a more brutal vigour, nor one which featured more battles or more sudden changes of fortune. The two cities which fought it were still at this time possessed of customs and institutions
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我打算完整地记述罗马与迦太基之间的第一次战争，这场战争是为了争夺西西里岛的控制权。之所以要这样做，是因为很难想象还有哪场冲突持续时间更长、双方投入的精力更多、进行的手段更残酷，或者包含更多的战役和更突如其来的命运转折。当时交战的两个城市仍然保留着
that were yet to fall into decadence. Both were dependent chiefly on their own efforts rather than on good luck for their successes, and both were equally matched in terms of their resources, which is why we can arrive at a more accurate assessment of the respective qualities and attributes of the two combatants in this particular war than we can by studying any comparable conflict. So that was the Greek writer Polybius talking about one of the titanic clashes, not just in ancient history, but Tom, in all history, it is the first Punic war between Rome and Carthage. It is. I guess the Carthaginians would have called it the first Roman war. So that's a
尚未走向颓废的习俗和制度。双方的成功主要依赖于自身的努力而非好运，且双方在资源方面旗鼓相当，这就是为什么我们能比研究任何类似的冲突更准确地评估这场特定战争中两个交战方的素质和属性。以上是希腊作家波利比乌斯对这场泰坦级冲突的评价，这不仅是古代史，汤姆，在整个人类历史上，这是罗马与迦太基之间的第一次布匿战争。确实如此。我想迦太基人会称之为第一次罗马战争。所以这是一个
perspective that perhaps we could try and keep in mind. But yes, it is the great superpower clash in antiquity. And the two sides are perfectly matched because Carthage is the whale, Rome is the elephant. Carthage's wealth is in trade. Rome's in her resources of manpower. Carthage has been a great power for centuries. Rome is essentially an upstart. So that I think is what Polybius is talking about when he says that this is so interesting, you can gauge the respective strengths of the two cities. And so we're in the third century BC, just for those people who haven't listened to previous episodes. Carthage is on the shores of North Africa, present day Tunis, maritime power,
我们或许可以试着铭记的视角。但没错，这是古代世界伟大的超级大国冲突。双方势均力敌，因为迦太基是鲸鱼，罗马是大象。迦太基的财富在于贸易，罗马的财富在于人力资源。迦太基几个世纪以来一直是一个大国，而罗马本质上是一个暴发户。所以我认为这就是波利比乌斯所说的，为什么这场战争如此有趣，你可以衡量这两个城市各自的实力。现在我们处于公元前三世纪，对于那些没有听过之前剧集的听众来说，迦太基位于北非海岸，即今天的突尼斯，是一个海上强国，
mercantile power, as you said. Rome has taken all Italy by now, has absorbed Latium, all these other people, Campania and so on, and has incorporated them into Roman-ness, hasn't it? Into its manpower. Lots of them, yes. And we talked in the previous episode about how up until this point, the fact that Rome and Carthage are so different has actually made them seem complementary rather than antagonistic. They have their own kind of dimensions, their own spheres in which they operate. So again, we looked at how there've been various peace treaties. They were allies against this Greek king called Pyrrhus, who had come over and defeated the Romans, but these had been Pyrrhic victories. And so effectively, the Romans had won the war. And we also mentioned how Pyrrhus, before he left to go back to Epirus's
正如你所说，是一个商业强国。罗马此时已经占领了整个意大利，吸收了拉齐奥、坎帕尼亚等所有其他地区，并将它们纳入了罗马体系，不是吗？纳入了它的人力资源。是的，很多人。我们在上一集中讨论过，直到这一点，罗马和迦太基如此不同，实际上使它们看起来是互补的，而不是对抗的。它们有各自的维度，各自运作的领域。所以我们再次回顾了它们之间曾有过各种和平条约。它们曾是盟友，共同对抗那位名叫皮洛士的希腊国王，他曾渡海击败过罗马人，但那些都是“皮洛士式的胜利”。因此，实际上，罗马人赢得了战争。我们还提到，皮洛士在离开返回伊庇鲁斯之前，
kingdom on the other side of the Adriatic, had looked at Sicily in particular, where Carthage for many, many centuries had established a sphere of influence in the western half of the island. And he'd said, Sicily will make a beautiful killing field for the Romans and the Carthaginians. So he's seeing that this is going to be the flashpoint. And I mean, he's not wrong because the Romans are in Rhaekium on the very toe of Italy. And of course, on the other side of the Straits, you have Messina, what back in classical times was Messana. And it's been argued that the Romans are nervous. They're nervous that the Carthaginians might, they've got this great fleet, that their control of the Italian coastline might leave them very
那个位于亚得里亚海另一边的王国，曾特别关注西西里岛，迦太基在那里几个世纪以来一直建立着势力范围，占据了岛屿的西半部。他说，西西里岛将成为罗马人和迦太基人美丽的杀戮场。所以他预见到这将是冲突的爆发点。我的意思是，他并没有错，因为罗马人当时就在意大利最脚尖处的雷吉乌姆。当然，在海峡的另一边，就是墨西拿，也就是古典时代的墨萨那。有人认为罗马人很紧张。他们担心迦太基人可能会利用他们强大的舰队，而他们对意大利海岸线的控制可能会使他们变得非常
exposed. But there's a very great scholar of Roman imperialism called William Harris who makes a brilliantly convincing case that war was inevitable above all because Rome is a state that is attuned to violence. There's this kind of mafiosi quality to them, never to accept disrespect. So just on that, obviously there comes a point in Roman history where they become more conservative. What we have we hold. Kind of, I don't know, Trajan or something. But at this point, would you say expansionism, imperialism for want of a better word, is absolutely built into their system,
脆弱。但有一位非常伟大的罗马帝国主义学者威廉·哈里斯提出了一个极其令人信服的观点，即战争之所以不可避免，首先是因为罗马是一个适应暴力的国家。他们有一种黑手党式的特质，绝不接受不敬。那么关于这一点，显然罗马历史上有一个阶段，他们变得更加保守。我们拥有的就是我们持有的。比如，我不知道，图拉真之类的。但在这一点上，你会说扩张主义，或者用一个更好的词来说，帝国主义，是绝对植入他们的系统中的吗？
partly because it's the credo of the Republic, but also because of the structural competition between different generals and so on. So you win political promotion and you win the honestas, the glorious reputation in the face of your fellow citizens by achieving great things for your city. And so that is kind of baked into the structure of Roman society. It has to be said that the Romans do not see themselves as predatory. They see themselves as a terribly moral people who essentially are going to war in self-defense. So there's this kind of weird thing that the Romans end up conquering the world
部分原因是这是共和国的信条，但也因为不同将军之间结构性的竞争等等。所以你通过为你的城市取得伟大的成就，来赢得政治晋升，并赢得公民同胞眼中的“荣誉”（honestas），即光荣的声誉。所以这在某种程度上已经融入了罗马社会的结构中。必须说，罗马人并不认为自己是掠夺性的。他们认为自己是一个极其道德的民族，本质上是为了自卫而发动战争。所以有一种奇怪的事情，罗马人最终在自卫中征服了世界，
effectively in self-defense. And they would say that the proof of the fact that they are a moral people is that the gods have favored them and brought them victory. So they don't see themselves as ruthless imperialists, although effectively that is what they are. But they are definitely a kind of new mutant element in this centuries-old conflict in Sicily between the Greeks and the Carthaginians. And on top of that, of course, the Greeks and the Carthaginians are known factors to each other. But I think Carthage also has reason to be hostile to Rome, actually, because, of course, the Greeks are. And he says, the Carthaginians, who had been a great power for so long, and the Romans, who were growing ever stronger by the year, could not help but cast envious eyes on each other. So that's what American geopolitical strategists today would call the Thucydides trap.
实际上是这样。他们会说，他们是道德民族的证据在于众神偏爱他们并带给他们胜利。所以他们并不认为自己是冷酷的帝国主义者，尽管实际上他们就是这样。但他们绝对是西西里岛希腊人和迦太基人之间这场持续数世纪的冲突中一种新的突变因素。最重要的是，当然，希腊人和迦太基人对彼此来说都是已知的因素。但我认为迦太基也有理由对罗马怀有敌意，事实上，因为希腊人当然是这样。他说，长期以来一直是大国的迦太基人，和一年比一年强大的罗马人，不禁对彼此投以嫉妒的目光。这就是今天美国地缘政治战略家所说的“修昔底德陷阱”。
Right, the US and China, or whatever. Yes, or Britain and Germany under the Kaiser. the anxiety of the established power and nervousness about a rising power. And so it's not surprising that it all kicks off in Messina. So the point that is nearest in Sicily to Italy. And there's a bunch of Italian mercenaries from Campania who are called the Mamatines after this brilliantly named god Mamas, who's an Italian war god. And they've been working for Agathocles, the tyrant of Syracuse, who had gone off, invaded Africa and then been defeated. And so they've been made redundant. And so they come to Mycenae and they seize control of it. And Hero, who is the king of Syracuse, he's a guy who's, as in the tradition
没错，美国和中国，或者其他什么。是的，或者凯撒统治下的英国和德国。既有既定大国的焦虑，也有对新兴大国的紧张。所以这一切在墨西拿爆发也就不足为奇了。也就是西西里岛距离意大利最近的地方。有一群来自坎帕尼亚的意大利雇佣兵，他们被称为马梅尔丁人，以这个名字响亮的战神马姆斯命名，他是一位意大利战神。他们曾为叙拉古的僭主阿加托克利斯效力，他曾出征并入侵非洲，随后被击败。所以他们被裁员了。于是他们来到墨西拿并夺取了控制权。而叙拉古的国王希罗，他是一个，按照
of Syracuse and tyrants, he comes from nowhere. He makes himself tyrant and then king of Syracuse. And he's doing what kings of Syracuse always do, which is to eye up opportunities in cities in Sicily that are going through domestic trouble. And so he looks and sees that these Mamertines have seized the city, that the Messenians don't really want them there. He advances against Messina to try and kick them out and take control of the city for himself. What the Mamertines do, they appeal to Carthage for help, which is again traditional. This is what you always do in Sicily, but just to hedge their bets, they also appeal to Rome. Carthaginians don't know this.
叙拉古僭主的传统，他出身卑微。他自封为僭主，然后成为叙拉古国王。他做着叙拉古国王总是做的事情，那就是盯着西西里岛那些正经历国内动荡的城市中的机会。于是他看到这些马梅尔丁人夺取了城市，而墨西拿人并不真的希望他们待在那里。他向墨西拿进军，试图将他们赶走，并为自己夺取城市的控制权。马梅尔丁人所做的是，他们向迦太基寻求帮助，这又是传统的做法。在西西里岛，你总是这样做，但为了分散风险，他们也向罗马求助。迦太基人不知道这一点。
So the Carthaginians, they move into Messina, they take control of it, and they think, brilliant, this is par for the course. But then a Roman agent turns up, actually a Claudius, one of this very distinguished political dynasty in Rome, the Claudians. And he wins the Mamertines over and gets them to expel the Carthaginians. So the Romans, most unexpectedly, to the surprise of both the expel the Carthaginians. So the Romans, most unexpectedly, to the surprise of both the Greeks and the Carthaginians, they've now seized control of Messina. And this, you can imagine, sends shockwaves through the entire island. And the Romans do what the Romans always do in this situation, which is to double down. So another
所以迦太基人进入了墨西拿，夺取了控制权，他们心想，太棒了，这很正常。但随后一名罗马特使出现了，实际上是克劳狄家族的一员，这是罗马一个非常显赫的政治王朝，克劳狄家族。他赢得了马梅尔丁人的支持，并让他们驱逐了迦太基人。所以罗马人，出人意料地，令希腊人和迦太基人都感到惊讶，他们现在夺取了墨西拿的控制权。你可以想象，这在整个岛屿上引起了轩然大波。而罗马人做了他们在这种情况下总是做的事情，那就是加倍下注。所以另一个
Claudius, who's the consul Appius Claudius, even though they don't have any ships, they commandeer fishing boats and all this kind of thing. And they arrive in Messina and they defeat a Syracusan army and they defeat a Carthaginian army. And in 263, 40,000 men and both consuls arrive in Messina. And this is enough to get all the Greek cities in Sicily to sign up to the Romans. He arose the Syracusan king. He sues for terms. The Romans agree that he can stay as king in Syracuse, effectively be independent, but from this point on, he has to serve as an ally of the Roman people. Within a couple of years, the Romans have basically established a supremacy over the Greek eastern half of Sicily. This is a nightmare for Carthage because they don't want the Romans
克劳狄，即执政官阿庇乌斯·克劳狄，尽管他们没有任何船只，但他们征用了渔船和所有这类东西。他们抵达墨西拿，击败了叙拉古军队，又击败了迦太基军队。公元前263年，4万名士兵和两位执政官抵达墨西拿。这足以让西西里岛所有的希腊城市都投靠罗马人。叙拉古国王希罗。他请求议和。罗马人同意他可以继续担任叙拉古国王，实际上保持独立，但从这一点开始，他必须作为罗马人民的盟友效力。几年之内，罗马人基本上确立了对西西里岛希腊东半部的统治地位。这对迦太基来说是一场噩梦，因为他们不希望罗马人
in Sicily. They know what they're dealing with with the Greeks, but not with the Romans. And do the Romans know, they must be conscious that this is unbelievably provocative to the Carthaginians who have been fighting the Greeks for control of Sicily for so long. So has that first Claudius done this on his own initiative and basically the Romans are being dragged in? It's a bit like the way that people say the British Empire was kind of, parts of it required in a kind of fit of absence of mind. Is it being centrally directed? Have people sat around a kind of map in Rome and said, this is the time? Has that happened? Well, it's interesting. There is some embarrassment around the Roman support for the Mamertines because the Mamertines have seized the city illegally. And so the Romans are a little bit
出现在西西里岛。他们知道如何与希腊人打交道，但不知道如何与罗马人打交道。罗马人知道吗？他们一定意识到这对迦太基人来说是难以置信的挑衅，因为迦太基人为了控制西西里岛已经与希腊人战斗了这么久。那么，第一个克劳狄是自作主张这样做的吗？罗马人基本上是被拖下水的吗？这有点像人们所说的大英帝国，其部分领土是在一种“心不在焉”的状态下获得的。这是中央指挥的吗？罗马有人围着地图说，时机到了吗？这发生过吗？嗯，这很有趣。罗马对马梅尔丁人的支持确实引起了一些尴尬，因为马梅尔丁人是非法夺取城市的。所以罗马人有点
nervous that maybe the Mamertines actually have offended the gods, they've offended the laws of hospitality. But they brush that aside. They convince themselves that they're entirely morally justified, that this is what the gods want. And so they pile in. And the fact that the Carthaginians are offended and demand the Roman withdrawal is seen as disrespect. And so the Romans are fully up for full-scale war. And the Carthaginians, because they are not prepared to tolerate the intrusion of this upstart power into their sphere of influence, likewise are completely committed to it. And the Carthaginians, although they respect Roman land forces, the Carthaginians are dependent on mercenaries. They don't have this kind of great body of citizens that the Romans can
紧张，也许马梅尔丁人确实冒犯了众神，他们冒犯了待客之道。但他们把这些抛在一边。他们说服自己，他们完全在道德上是正当的，这就是众神想要的。所以他们蜂拥而至。迦太基人感到被冒犯并要求罗马撤军，这被视为不敬。所以罗马人完全准备好进行全面战争了。而迦太基人，因为他们不准备容忍这个暴发户势力侵入他们的势力范围，同样也完全投入其中。迦太基人，尽管他们尊重罗马的陆军，但迦太基人依赖雇佣兵。他们没有罗马人可以指挥的那种
command. They're confident of victory because of course, Sicily is an island. They are the great maritime power and the Romans don't have a fleet. So Carthage thinks we can ace this. And so what they do, so there's a place, Lilibaeum, which is on the furthest most western point. Pernormus, which is Palermo, modern day Palermo. Palermo is an old Phoenician city. Lilibaeum was deliberately founded to be an impregnable fortress of Carthaginian power. But what they actually decide to do is to seize control of a Greek city, Akragas, modern day Agrigento, because it's further to the east on the southern coast. So it's towards where the Romans are operating, but it can be easily supplied from Carthage.
伟大的公民群体。他们对胜利充满信心，因为当然，西西里岛是一个岛屿。他们是伟大的海上强国，而罗马人没有舰队。所以迦太基认为我们可以搞定这个。于是他们所做的是，有一个地方叫利利巴伊姆，位于最西端。帕诺尔穆斯，即巴勒莫，现代的巴勒莫。巴勒莫是一座古老的腓尼基城市。利利巴伊姆被特意建立为迦太基权力的坚不可摧的堡垒。但他们实际上决定做的是夺取一座希腊城市，阿格里真托，现代的阿格里真托，因为它位于南海岸更靠东的地方。所以它靠近罗马人的活动区域，但可以很容易地从迦太基获得补给。
It's a Greek city. It's famous for having been once ruled by a notorious tyrant who used to boil people to death inside a great bronze bull. And it's large and prosperous. There are kind of maybe 25,000, 30,000 people there. And they fortify it. The Romans pile in, they besiege it. Carthage sends a huge relief force, 60 elephants, all the works. And Dominic, I'm sure you can guess the name of the guy in charge of it. He's yet another Hanno, is he? He is a Hanno. He's yet another Hanno. Yes. But this is a terrible, he's a terrible general. So he lands with his forces
这是一座希腊城市。它以曾经被一位臭名昭著的僭主统治而闻名，他曾把人煮死在一头巨大的铜牛里。它很大且繁荣。那里大约有25,000到30,000人。他们加固了它。罗马人蜂拥而至，围攻它。迦太基派出一支庞大的救援部队，60头大象，应有尽有。多米尼克，我相信你能猜出负责人的名字。他又是一个汉诺，对吧？他确实是一个汉诺。是的。但这很糟糕，他是一个糟糕的将军。所以他带着他的部队登陆了，
and he looks down from a hill at the Romans and he thinks, oh, I don't really want to fight them. A bit nervous of it. So he just stays there for two months. And then finally, because we should say, we mentioned this a couple of episodes ago, but the penalty for failure in Carthage is very, very severe. So at the worst, you can be crucified, but it's not good. So finally, he thinks, well, I better crack on. So he advances against the Romans, but it's a disaster. The Romans stand firm. The elephants stampede. They trample their own men. It's a complete catastrophe. And the commander of the Carthaginian garrison in Acragas realizes that all is lost. And so he and his garrison slip out. They fill the Roman trenches
他从山上俯视罗马人，心想，哦，我真的不想和他们打。有点紧张。所以他就在那里待了两个月。最后，因为我们应该说，我们在几集前提到过，在迦太基，失败的代价是非常非常严重的。最坏的情况，你可能会被钉死在十字架上，这可不好。所以最后，他想，好吧，我最好还是行动起来。于是他向罗马人进军，但这是一场灾难。罗马人坚守阵地。大象惊慌失措。它们践踏了自己的士兵。这是一场彻底的灾难。阿格里真托的迦太基驻军指挥官意识到一切都完了。于是他和他的驻军溜了出去。他们填平了罗马人的战壕，
with straw, manage to get across Scarpa. The Romans move into Acragas, sack it, sell all its inhabitants into slavery. And meanwhile, back in Carthage, Hanno loses all his civil rights and it has a massive fine slapped on him. Right. Could have been worse. Could have been crucified. Yeah, it absolutely could have been worse. And back in Rome, the news that they have brushed off the Carthaginians so easily kind of determines them in their conviction that they should kick the Carthaginians out of Sicily altogether. The Carthaginians, they rely very heavily on mercenaries, don't they? So even at this stage, they rely on some mercenaries in a way the Romans aren't? Yeah, basically their troops are all mercenaries.
用稻草，设法穿过了斯卡帕。罗马人进入阿格里真托，洗劫了它，把所有居民卖为奴隶。与此同时，在迦太基，汉诺失去了所有的公民权利，并被处以巨额罚款。好吧。本来可能更糟。本来可能被钉死在十字架上。是的，绝对可能更糟。而在罗马，他们如此轻易地击退了迦太基人的消息，使他们更加坚信应该将迦太基人完全赶出西西里岛。迦太基人非常依赖雇佣兵，不是吗？所以即使在这个阶段，他们依赖一些雇佣兵的方式也是罗马人所没有的？是的，基本上他们的军队全是雇佣兵。
So obviously the problem though for the Romans is that if they're going to conquer Sicily, let alone hold it, they do need a fleet. And this is a real challenge because Carthage is the greatest naval power of its day. It's got centuries of maritime experience. It's the inventor, Dominic, of the quadrareme, which is a ship that is bigger and more powerful than the trireme right so it has kind of four banks of oars and it also has lots of quincarines which is battleships with five bounds of oars which had been invented by the syracusans so they're basically the kind of the dreadnoughts of the ancient world and the romans don't have any of these but this is exactly the kind of challenge the romans relish. A quincarim has been shipwrecked on the Italian coast,
所以显然罗马人的问题是，如果他们要征服西西里岛，更不用说守住它，他们确实需要一支舰队。这是一个真正的挑战，因为迦太基是当时最伟大的海军强国。它有几个世纪的海上经验。多米尼克，它是四层桨战船的发明者，这是一种比三层桨战船更大、更强大的船，对吧？所以它有四排桨，而且它还有很多五层桨战船，也就是有五排桨的战舰，这是叙拉古人发明的，所以它们基本上是古代世界的“无畏舰”，而罗马人没有任何这些。但这正是罗马人所喜欢的挑战。一艘五层桨战船在意大利海岸沉没了，
the Carthaginian quincarim. They take it and they disassemble it. The way the Carthaginians build ships, and we know this because the shipwreck of one of them has been found, they kind of built them in the way that you might build a cabinet from ikea they're kind of flat packs they're kind of numbered pieces and you can stick them all together and so this actually makes it quite easy for the romans to work out how to build oh just to copy it yeah yeah just to copy it and so they do this and they build 100 quink reams 20 tri reams and polybius you know our greek historian who's our main source for this terribly terribly impressed. And he says of this, that nothing better illustrates the remarkable spirit and boldness of the Romans.
那是一艘迦太基的五层桨战船。他们把它拆解了。迦太基人建造船只的方式，我们知道这一点是因为其中一艘沉船被发现了，他们建造它们的方式就像你可能从宜家组装橱柜一样，它们是那种扁平包装的，它们是那种编号的零件，你可以把它们全部粘在一起，所以这实际上使罗马人很容易弄清楚如何建造，哦，只是复制它，是的，是的，只是复制它。于是他们就这样做了，他们建造了100艘五层桨战船，20艘三层桨战船，波利比乌斯，你知道我们那位希腊历史学家，他是我们这个的主要来源，非常非常印象深刻。他对此评价说，没有什么比这更能说明罗马人非凡的精神和胆识了。
And so they build this great fleet. None of the Romans have any naval experience at all, but they kind of go sailing down to try and confront the Carthaginians. And it's an absolute disaster. They sail into an enemy harbour. The Carthaginians come out, all the crews panic, jump into the sea, and the whole force is taken prisoner. But does this put the Romans off? Probably not.
于是他们建造了这支伟大的舰队。罗马人中没有任何人有任何海军经验，但他们还是出海去试图对抗迦太基人。结果是一场彻底的灾难。他们驶入了一个敌人的港口。迦太基人出来，所有的船员都惊慌失措，跳入海中，整支部队都被俘虏了。但这会让罗马人退缩吗？可能不会。
No, it doesn't. Because the Romans realise that they're never going to be able to match the Carthaginians in terms of their mobility, the art of ramming a ship, all that kind of stuff. But what the Romans are really good at is, of course, fighting on land. The Roman wheeze is to turn naval battles into land battles. They do this by inventing a thing they call the corvus, which is a crow. It's a kind of boarding bridge that has a huge, great spike on the end, like the beak of a crow or a raven. You sail up beside the enemy ship and you release this and the spike sinks into the boards of the enemy ship. Then all your soldiers, your marines, can pile across, slaughter the enemy and seize control of the enemy ship. It's a brilliant invention. No one thought of it before. So the Romans, very excited, they sail out. And in 260, they creep up on the Carthaginian fleet, who have no idea what's about to hit them,
不，并没有。因为罗马人意识到，在机动性、撞击船只的艺术以及所有这些方面，他们永远无法与迦太基人相比。但罗马人真正擅长的是，当然，在陆地上战斗。罗马人的妙计是将海战变成陆战。他们通过发明一种他们称之为“乌鸦”（corvus）的东西来做到这一点。这是一种登船桥，末端有一个巨大的尖刺，就像乌鸦或渡鸦的喙。你驶到敌船旁边，释放这个装置，尖刺就会沉入敌船的甲板。然后你所有的士兵，你的海军陆战队，就可以冲过去，屠杀敌人并夺取敌船的控制权。这是一个天才的发明。以前没有人想到过。所以罗马人非常兴奋，他们出海了。公元前260年，他们悄悄接近迦太基舰队，他们根本不知道会发生什么，
at a place called Meli off northern Sicily. And it's a tremendous success. They win. And again, Polybius says it's the battle became exactly like a battle on land. Right, so they've turned it into the kind of battle that they know and are very proficient at. Yes, absolutely. And for the Carthaginians, you can imagine this is a tremendous shock to be beaten by a bunch of landlubbers. And so the remnants of the Carthaginian fleet sail off to Sardinia and they're so pissed off
在一个叫米莱的地方，在西西里岛北部。这是一次巨大的成功。他们赢了。波利比乌斯再次说，这场战斗变得完全像一场陆战。没错，所以他们把它变成了他们所熟悉且非常精通的那种战斗。是的，绝对是。对于迦太基人来说，你可以想象被一群旱鸭子击败是一个巨大的打击。所以迦太基舰队的残部驶向撒丁岛，他们非常恼火，
with the Carthaginian admiral. They don't fine him, Dominic. They don't deprive him of his civic rights. They crucify him. And Tom, as you've noted there, this is a battle referred to in T.S. Eliot's The Wasteland. Yes, very sinister passage. The first part of it, isn't it? Stetson, you who were with me in the ships at Melite, that corpse you planted last year in your garden, has it begun to sprout? I wonder why, well, I don't know why T.S. Eliot chose that particular battle. Do you know, Tom? I think because the scale of slaughter and fighting in this war must have reminded Eliot of the scale of slaughter in fighting in this war must have reminded Eliot of the scale of slaughter in the First World War, the horror of it. And it just goes on and on and
对迦太基海军上将。多米尼克，他们没有罚他款。他们没有剥夺他的公民权利。他们把他钉死在十字架上了。汤姆，正如你所指出的，这是一场在T.S.艾略特的《荒原》中提到的战役。是的，非常阴险的段落。第一部分，不是吗？“斯泰森，你曾与我一起在米莱的船上，你去年种在花园里的那具尸体，它开始发芽了吗？”我不知道为什么，嗯，我不知道为什么T.S.艾略特选择了那场特定的战役。你知道吗，汤姆？我想是因为这场战争中屠杀和战斗的规模一定让艾略特想起了第一次世界大战中屠杀和战斗的规模，那种恐怖。它没完没了，
on because even though, you know, Mylae is a great victory, but it doesn't bring the Carthaginians to defeat at all. Because weirdly, despite the fact the Romans have now won at sea, they're actually doing quite badly in the land war in Sicily because the Carthaginians, just as the Romans have learned how to fight on the sea, the Carthaginians have learned how to fight the Romans on land. And they do it by avoiding pitch battle, by adopting guerrilla tactics. And the Romans, a bit like the Americans in Vietnam, or European colonial powers, get so cross with this that they start conducting reprisals against local populations. They lose hearts and minds. And their control over Greek Sicily starts to kind of wobble.
而且因为即使，你知道，米莱是一场伟大的胜利，但它根本没有导致迦太基人的失败。因为奇怪的是，尽管罗马人现在在海上赢了，但他们在西西里岛的陆战中实际上表现得很糟糕，因为迦太基人，就像罗马人学会了如何在海上战斗一样，迦太基人也学会了如何在陆地上对抗罗马人。他们通过避免正面交锋，采取游击战术来做到这一点。而罗马人，有点像越南战争中的美国人，或者欧洲殖民大国，对此感到非常愤怒，以至于他们开始对当地居民进行报复。他们失去了民心。他们对希腊西西里岛的控制开始动摇。
And so in 256, that's four years after Meli, they decide to do what the Romans have always been good at, which is going for the jugular. And they decide to follow the example that had been set by Agathocles, the Syracusan tyrant who had invaded Africa, and launch a full-blown invasion of Carthage itself. They've got by now 330 ships, and they load these ships with 140,000 men. Both the consuls are in charge of this great armada, sails across the Mediterranean towards Africa, and the Carthaginians sail out to oppose them with a fleet that has 150,000 men.
所以公元前256年，也就是米莱战役四年后，他们决定做罗马人一直擅长的事情，那就是直捣黄龙。他们决定效仿叙拉古僭主阿加托克利斯的榜样，他曾入侵非洲，并对迦太基本身发动全面入侵。他们现在有330艘船，他们装载了14万名士兵。两位执政官都负责这支伟大的无敌舰队，横跨地中海驶向非洲，而迦太基人派出了一支拥有15万人的舰队来对抗他们。
Can we rely on these numbers? Or are these made up according to the Roman literary practice of inflation? I think we probably can. And even if they're not precise, they reflect a fact that is noted by Greeks at the time and gets kind of reported by Polybius, our favourite Greek source. It's seen as being a battle beyond the dreams of people in the eastern half of the Mediterranean, so that the Greek world is accustomed to think of itself as these are the great powers. And now suddenly they're getting reports of this battle, which is on a scale larger than anything they could comprehend.
我们能相信这些数字吗？还是这些是根据罗马文学夸大的惯例编造的？我想我们大概可以相信。即使它们不精确，它们也反映了一个事实，即当时希腊人注意到了这一点，并被我们最喜欢的希腊来源波利比乌斯报道了。这被视为一场超出了地中海东半部人们梦想的战斗，所以希腊世界习惯于认为自己是这些大国。而现在突然间，他们收到了这场战斗的报告，其规模之大超出了他们所能理解的任何事物。
And it always reminds me of the Battle of the Midway in the Second World War between the Americans and Japanese fleets, and how Europeans must have felt this is a different order of conflict completely. So I think it's generally held to have been the single largest naval battle in antiquity. And it's a victory for the Romans. They win. So they land in Africa, they capture various towns, they establish a bridgehead. Having done that, one of the two consuls is ordered home
这总是让我想起第二次世界大战中美国和日本舰队之间的中途岛海战，以及欧洲人当时一定觉得这完全是另一种冲突。所以我认为它通常被认为是古代规模最大的一次海战。这是一场罗马人的胜利。所以他们在非洲登陆，占领了各个城镇，建立了桥头堡。做到这一点后，其中一位执政官被命令回国，
because the Romans obviously don't want to stake everything on this throne. They want to keep reserves. One of the two consuls, a guy called Regulus, is ordered to stay there. He has 40 ships, 15,000 infantry, 500 cavalry. The figures come from Polybius. He goes out, he defeats a Carthaginian army that has come out to meet him. He captures more cities, and then he institutes a blockade of Carthage. The Carthaginians say, okay, well, this isn't looking good. Let's have peace negotiations. But Regulus, the terms he demands are too harsh. So the key sticking point is that he demands that Carthage surrender Sardinia and Sicily. And I think it's particularly Sicily.
因为罗马人显然不想把一切都押在这个赌注上。他们想保留预备队。其中一位执政官，一个叫雷古鲁斯的人，被命令留在那里。他有40艘船，1.5万名步兵，500名骑兵。这些数字来自波利比乌斯。他出征，击败了一支出来迎接他的迦太基军队。他占领了更多的城市，然后对迦太基实施了封锁。迦太基人说，好吧，这看起来不太好。让我们进行和平谈判吧。但雷古鲁斯要求的条件太苛刻了。所以关键的症结在于，他要求迦太基割让撒丁岛和西西里岛。我认为特别是西西里岛。
The Carthaginians are not prepared to give up their half of Sicily, which by now has come to seem as much Carthaginian territory as the lands around Carthage itself. And that would mean their relegation from the Champions League places, as it were, wouldn't it? I mean, if they lost such an important and rich territory that was psychologically so important to them? Yes, I think so. But I think it's the fact that they see it as being theirs. It would be like Britain being required to surrender Yorkshire or something. I mean, they see it as being part of their territory. That means that they, like the Romans, are determined to fight on. And as it happens, they have a guy on hand who is perfectly qualified to defeat the Romans because this is a Spartan called Xanthippus. So we talked about how the Carthaginians employ mercenaries. He's a mercenary. And because he's a Spartan, he's tremendously good at drill. And he works out the best drills to defeat the Romans. And all the people in the Carthaginian army decide that actually he is the best qualified
迦太基人没有准备好放弃他们那一半的西西里岛，到目前为止，这看起来已经和迦太基周围的土地一样，是迦太基的领土了。那意味着他们被降级出了“冠军联赛”，不是吗？我的意思是，如果他们失去了如此重要和富饶的领土，而这在心理上对他们又如此重要？是的，我想是这样。但我认为这是因为他们认为这是他们的。这就像英国被要求割让约克郡一样。我的意思是，他们认为这是他们领土的一部分。这意味着他们像罗马人一样，决心继续战斗。碰巧的是，他们手头有一个人，他完全有资格击败罗马人，因为这是一个叫克桑提波斯的斯巴达人。所以我们谈到了迦太基人如何雇佣雇佣兵。他就是一名雇佣兵。而且因为他是斯巴达人，他非常擅长操练。他研究出了击败罗马人的最佳操练方法。而迦太基军队中的所有人都认为，实际上他是最有资格
to lead them. And so rather than be led by a Carthaginian general, they demand to be led by Xanthippus. And Xanthippus' drills turn out to be tremendous. He's very good at tactics. He goes out to meet Regulus. The Romans are annihilated. And he's using good at tactics he goes out to meet regulus the romans are annihilated and he's using elephants right he's using elephants the elephants crash into the roman infantry the cavalry on the wings sees off the roman cavalry and the whole roman army gets enveloped and wiped out and regulus himself is taken prisoner now in due course the story comes to be told about regulus that the carthaginians send him back to Rome to persuade the Romans to surrender. And Regulus goes back to Rome and he tells the Senate on no account surrender.
领导他们的人。所以与其由迦太基将军领导，他们要求由克桑提波斯领导。而克桑提波斯的操练结果非常惊人。他非常擅长战术。他出去迎接雷古鲁斯。罗马人被歼灭了。而且他正在使用大象，对吧？他正在使用大象。大象冲进罗马步兵阵中，侧翼的骑兵击溃了罗马骑兵，整个罗马军队被包围并消灭，雷古鲁斯本人也被俘虏了。现在，随着时间的推移，关于雷古鲁斯的故事流传开来，说迦太基人把他送回罗马，试图说服罗马人投降。雷古鲁斯回到罗马，他告诉元老院，无论如何都不要投降。
Keep fighting. Tom, I translated this when I was at school. I remember this story very well. It's a very noble, inspiring story. And then Regulus, rather than staying in rome because he feels duty bound goes back yeah to carthage amazing and when he gets back to carthage there are various accounts that kind of escalate over the centuries the story is told so cicero says that he's put in a box with spikes in it so that he can't kind of lean against it augustine says that he's put in a barrel with
继续战斗。汤姆，我上学时翻译过这段。我记得这个故事非常清楚。这是一个非常高尚、鼓舞人心的故事。然后雷古鲁斯，与其留在罗马，因为他觉得有责任，又回到了迦太基。太神奇了。当他回到迦太基时，有各种各样的说法，随着几个世纪的故事流传，故事不断升级。西塞罗说他被关进了一个带钉子的盒子里，这样他就不能靠在上面了。奥古斯丁说他被放进了一个桶里，
spikes driven in it and kind of rolled down the hill. Yeah. So a tremendous story. It's not true. Oh, Tom. It's not true. I said last time that I thought you were better than this. And yet again, you've let your podcast down. How do you know it's not true? Don't tell me Regulus died happily in his bed at the age of 82.
钉子钉在里面，然后被滚下山坡。是的。所以这是一个了不起的故事。这不是真的。哦，汤姆。这不是真的。我上次说我觉得你比这更好。然而你又一次让你的播客失望了。你怎么知道这不是真的？别告诉我雷古鲁斯在82岁时在床上幸福地去世了。
We don't know what happened to him. He probably just dies in Carthage. It comes to be told because it serves to illustrate this idea that Punic faith is treachery. Roman faith is honesty. He's given his word and it's a kind of stirring patriotic tale. And in fact, Augustine loves it because it reminds him of Christian martyrs. And so he says that Regulus was the noblest Roman of them all, even though it didn't actually happen. But the salient fact is that the Roman are defeated in Africa. And then the year after this, they lose two fleets in a row to violent storms. So 300 ships are lost, 100,000 men are drowned. So this is the point again, where if this was a normal war, the kind of war that the Greeks and the Carthaginians had been
我们不知道他发生了什么。他可能只是死在迦太基了。这个故事之所以流传，是因为它有助于说明“布匿诚信”（Punic faith）就是背信弃义，而罗马诚信就是诚实。他信守诺言，这是一个令人振奋的爱国故事。事实上，奥古斯丁很喜欢它，因为它让他想起了基督教殉道者。所以他说雷古鲁斯是所有罗马人中最崇高的，尽管这并没有真正发生。但最突出的事实是，罗马人在非洲被击败了。然后在那之后的一年，他们连续两次在猛烈的风暴中损失了舰队。所以300艘船沉没，10万人淹死。所以这又是这一点，如果这是一场正常的战争，希腊人和迦太基人一直在
fighting, the Romans would have negotiated. Greeks and the Carthaginians had been fighting, the Romans would have negotiated. Peace treaties would have been opened up. There would have been spheres of influence in Sicily decided. But the Romans don't do this. They just keep coming back. And they keep suffering terrible losses at sea because they win the battles. But because they're not skilled mariners, they can't read the waves. They can't read the weather. They keep getting storms. And the most notorious example of this, which is mentioned in I Claudius, it's the first time I came across it, is that in 249 BC, a Roman fleet under another Claudius, Publius Claudius Pulcher, are sent to launch an attack on a port held by the Carthaginians
进行的战争，罗马人会进行谈判。和平条约会被开启。西西里岛的势力范围会被决定。但罗马人没有这样做。他们只是不断回来。他们不断在海上遭受惨重损失，因为他们赢得了战斗。但因为他们不是熟练的水手，他们看不懂海浪。他们看不懂天气。他们不断遇到风暴。最臭名昭著的例子，在《我，克劳狄》中提到过，这是我第一次看到它，是公元前249年，一支由另一个克劳狄，普布利乌斯·克劳狄·普尔赫尔率领的罗马舰队，被派去对迦太基人控制的一个港口发动攻击，
called Drapana in Sicily. And Claud Claudius' fleet is stationed off Drapana. He wants to attack. The Romans have to consult the sacred chickens to find out whether the gods are in favour. The report comes back that the chickens are refusing to eat their food, to which Claudius says they must be thirsty. He goes, he picks them up and he throws them in the sea. He then sails in, gets absolutely annihilated and only 30 Roman ships survive. So it's an absolute disaster. Claudius goes back to Rome, gets prosecuted, heavily fined. And there's another notorious story that his sister, Claudia, she's trying to get through a crowd in the forum and she can't because it's so thick.
叫德拉帕纳，在西西里岛。克劳狄的舰队驻扎在德拉帕纳外。他想进攻。罗马人必须咨询神圣的鸡，看看众神是否赞成。报告回来说，鸡拒绝吃东西，克劳狄对此说它们一定是渴了。他走过去，把它们抓起来扔进海里。然后他驶入，被彻底歼灭，只有30艘罗马船只幸存。所以这是一场彻底的灾难。克劳狄回到罗马，被起诉，被重罚。还有一个臭名昭著的故事，他的妹妹克劳迪娅，她试图穿过广场上的人群，但因为人太挤了，她过不去。
And she's said to have cried out, I wish my brother would lose another battle. In other words, the population of Rome would be thinned out. These are cited as examples of Claudian arrogance. The Claudians are either very noble, like Appius Claudius, the guy who had persuaded the Romans to fight on against Pyrrhus, or they're the kind of people who chuck sacred chickens into the sea or kind of wish defeat on the Romans. But in Sicily itself, the Romans are starting to really grind the Carthaginians down. So in 254, they capture Palermo, which Polybius describes as being the strongest Carthaginian city in Sicily. Other Carthaginians follow, and every attempt to oppose
据说她大喊道：“我希望我哥哥再输一场战役。”换句话说，罗马的人口会被减少。这些被引用为克劳狄家族傲慢的例子。克劳狄家族要么非常高尚，比如阿庇乌斯·克劳狄，那个说服罗马人继续对抗皮洛士的人，要么就是那种把神圣的鸡扔进海里，或者诅咒罗马人失败的人。但在西西里岛本身，罗马人开始真正地磨损迦太基人。所以公元前254年，他们占领了巴勒莫，波利比乌斯将其描述为西西里岛最强大的迦太基城市。其他迦太基城市随之而来，每一次试图在战斗中对抗
the Romans in battle ends in disaster for the Carthaginians.. Every attempt to oppose the Romans in battle ends in disaster for the Carthaginians. Every year, it seems, captured elephants are being paraded through the streets of Rome until by 250, only two strongholds are left. Drapana, which is the port that had been saved by the chicken-related incident, Claudius, and the great, great naval base of Lilibaeum, this naval fortress with its massive walls and its moat. The Carthaginians invest it in 250, but it holds out and it's really starting to look bad for Carthage now. So they've lost almost all their territory except for these two cities. The sea lanes can no longer be relied upon because the Romans have these fleets. And as a result of
罗马人的尝试都以迦太基人的灾难告终。每年似乎都有被俘的大象在罗马街头游行，直到公元前250年，只剩下两个据点。德拉帕纳，那个被与鸡有关的事件所拯救的港口，克劳狄，以及伟大的海军基地利利巴伊姆，这座拥有巨大城墙和护城河的海军堡垒。迦太基人在公元前250年围攻它，但它坚持住了，现在对迦太基来说情况真的开始变得糟糕了。所以他们几乎失去了除这两个城市之外的所有领土。海上航线不再可靠，因为罗马人拥有这些舰队。结果，
that, they are losing money. And if a result of that, they are losing money. And if they're losing money, they're losing manpower because they need money to pay for their mercenaries. So it's looking terrible. It's a death spiral, Tom. It is a death spiral. And they need a hero. Where are they going to find a hero, Dominic?
他们正在亏钱。如果他们亏钱，他们就会失去人力，因为他们需要钱来支付雇佣兵。所以情况看起来很糟糕。这是一个死亡螺旋，汤姆。这是一个死亡螺旋。他们需要一个英雄。多米尼克，他们去哪里找英雄？
Well, I think they'll probably find one after the break, won't they? They will. It'll be a very short podcast. But I think the exciting thing for our listeners is they are going to find a hero and this is going to be one of the most thrilling comebacks
嗯，我想他们可能会在休息后找到一个，不是吗？他们会找到的。这将是一个非常简短的播客。但我认为对我们的听众来说，令人兴奋的是他们将找到一个英雄，这将是人类历史上最激动人心的卷土重来之一。
in the history of humankind. So on that bombshell, please join us after the break to find out who that hero is. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host
所以带着这个重磅消息，请在休息后加入我们，找出那个英雄是谁。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. The trireme advanced in fierce and haughty fashion, cleaving the foam around it, the latine yard quite square and the sail bulging down the whole length of the mast. Its gigantic oars kept time as they beat the water.
《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉您它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。三层桨战船以凶猛而傲慢的姿态前进，劈开周围的泡沫，拉丁帆桁相当方正，帆在桅杆的全长上鼓起。它巨大的桨在击水时保持着节奏。
Every now and then the extremity of the keel, which was shaped like a ploughshare, would appear, and the ivory-headed horse, rearing both its feet beneath the spur which terminated the prow, would seem to be speeding over the plains of the sea. As it rounded the promontory, the wind ceased, the sail fell, and a man was seen standing bare-headed beside the pilot. It was he, Hamilcar the Suffet. About his sides he wore gleaming sheets of steel. A red cloak fastened to his shoulders left his arms visible. Two pearls of great length hung from his ears and his black bushy beard rested on his throat. Gustav Flaubert's novel Salambo of the hero of Carthage, Hamilcar the Suffet, Hamilcar Barker, one of the great names, Tom,
不时地，形状像犁铧的龙骨末端会出现，而象牙头的马，在船头末端的马刺下抬起双脚，似乎在海面上飞驰。当它绕过海角时，风停了，帆落下了，一个人被看到站在领航员旁边，赤着头。那是他，迦太基的执政官哈米尔卡。他的腰间穿着闪闪发光的钢片。一件红色的斗篷系在他的肩膀上，露出了他的手臂。两颗长长的珍珠挂在他的耳朵上，他那浓密的黑胡子靠在他的喉咙上。古斯塔夫·福楼拜的小说《萨朗波》中迦太基的英雄，执政官哈米尔卡，哈米尔卡·巴卡，古代最伟大的名字之一，汤姆，
of antiquity. And he is the man who is going to save the Carthaginians' bacon in this terrible mess they've got themselves in against the Romans. Or is he?
他就是那个要在迦太基人对抗罗马人的这场可怕混乱中拯救他们的人。或者他是吗？
So you said before the break that this is one of the great comebacks. I think, to be honest, it's more of a holding operation. But that is not to be underestimated. So Hamilcar, he's appointed commander-in-chief of Carthaginian forces in Sicily in 247. There aren't many Carthaginian forces in Sicily by this point, but they are his to command. He is from a very distinguished family. Carthage is an aristocratic republic, and so you tend not to be appointed unless you are distinguished. Actually, he claims to be descended from a brother of Elissa or Dido, the legendary founder of Carthage. He's relatively
所以你在休息前说这是一次伟大的复出。老实说，我认为这更像是一种防御性行动。但这不容小觑。哈米尔卡在公元前247年被任命为迦太基驻西西里军队的总司令。当时西西里的迦太基军队并不多，但都归他指挥。他出身名门。迦太基是一个贵族共和国，所以除非你出身显赫，否则通常不会被任命。事实上，他声称自己是迦太基传奇创始人埃莉莎或狄多兄弟的后裔。他相对
young, and he is famously energetic. He's famously proactive, and so much so that he gets the nickname of Barker, which seems to have meant kind of lightning. So he's Hamilcar the lightning bolt. As he sails from Carthage, he is leaving behind a daughter and a wife who is pregnant with another child and who in due course will turn out to be a son. This will be the first of three boys. So bear that in mind. Hamilcar's eldest son is being born while he is away in Sicily, where it has to be said the situation is completely grim because there isn't any money and without money, they can't afford to pay the mercenaries. So there are about 10,000 infantry, few cavalry, and these two strongholds, Drapena and Lilibaeum, both of whom are under siege. So what Hamilcar decides to do, he thinks there's no
年轻，而且以精力充沛著称。他以积极主动闻名，以至于得到了“巴卡”这个绰号，这似乎意味着“闪电”。所以他是“闪电”哈米尔卡。当他从迦太基启航时，他留下了一个女儿和一位怀着另一个孩子的妻子，后来证明那是个儿子。这将是三个男孩中的第一个。所以请记住这一点。哈米尔卡的长子在他远在西西里时出生，不得不说那里的情况非常严峻，因为没有钱，没有钱就付不起雇佣兵的工资。所以大约有10000名步兵，少量骑兵，还有两个据点，德拉帕纳和利利巴厄姆，都处于被围困状态。所以哈米尔卡决定，他认为没有
point in launching myself at the Romans. What I will do is I will establish myself as a kind of guerrilla commander in the heights outside Pernormus, which he does. And he finds this spot, Hayicte it's called, which I've never actually been to Palermo, so I'm not familiar with the geography, but apparently the consensus is that it was in the mountains five miles west of what's now Palermo. And it was easily defended. It had fresh water, it had pasturage for the horses, and most importantly, it had access to the sea. So from here, he's able to launch his lightning raids. But the downside, of course, is that he can't actually do anything to relieve Lillebeum or Drapana. He doesn't have the resources. And so that's why I mean that it's not really a comeback. It's basically
意义直接冲向罗马人。我要做的是在帕诺姆斯高地建立一个游击指挥部，他也确实这么做了。他找到了这个地方，叫海克特，我从来没去过巴勒莫，所以对地理不熟悉，但显然大家的共识是它位于现在巴勒莫以西五英里的山区。它易守难攻。那里有淡水，有马匹的牧场，最重要的是，它靠近大海。所以从这里，他能够发动闪电突袭。但缺点当然是，他实际上无法做任何事情来解救利利巴厄姆或德拉帕纳。他没有资源。这就是为什么我说这并不是真正的复出。这基本上
he is able to preserve a stalemate. And considering how little money he has, how few troops he has, I mean, that's not bad, but it's not a strategy that is going to enable Carthage to win the war. And of course, as the years go by and Hamilcar is there for six years, the numbers that he has start to fray. So in 244, he abandons his position outside Panormus and he goes to another place, a small town called Erix, which had been captured by the Romans. Hamilcar takes it back and this is just outside Drapana. And he stays camp there for two more years, harrying the Roman siege. But again, the same problem, not enough men to lift it completely. So by 242, the great crisis of the war is approaching because the Romans are locked
是他能够维持僵局。考虑到他资金匮乏，兵力稀少，这已经不错了，但这并不是一个能让迦太基赢得战争的战略。当然，随着岁月流逝，哈米尔卡在那里待了六年，他的人数开始减少。所以在公元前244年，他放弃了帕诺姆斯外的阵地，去了另一个地方，一个叫埃里克斯的小镇，那里曾被罗马人占领。哈米尔卡夺回了它，这就在德拉帕纳外面。他在那里扎营了两年，骚扰罗马人的围攻。但同样的问题，没有足够的人手彻底解除围困。所以到了公元前242年，战争的重大危机即将来临，因为罗马人被困在
in the stalemate and they recognise that the only way ultimately they can force a victory is decisively to defeat the Carthaginians at sea. So even though they've lost fleet after fleet after fleet to the weather, they decide that they will build one more armada. And by this point, Rome too is very skint. And so they take patriotic loans from the richest men in the Republic. Right. War bonds. War bonds, that kind of thing. And they're able to, by the skin of their teeth, to build a fleet of 200 ships. And that's somehow 242. It sails for Sicily under command of one of the two consuls,
僵局中，他们意识到最终能迫使胜利的唯一方法就是在海上决定性地击败迦太基人。所以尽管他们因为天气原因损失了一支又一支舰队，他们还是决定再建造一支无敌舰队。到这个时候，罗马也已经非常拮据了。于是他们向共和国最富有的人借了爱国贷款。没错。战争债券。战争债券之类的东西。他们勉强凑齐了，建造了一支200艘船的舰队。不知怎么的，到了公元前242年。它在两位执政官之一的指挥下驶向西西里，
Quintus Lutatius Caculus, and it takes the Carthaginians completely by surprise. The Carthaginians, I mean, some people have said they were lethargic. Others have said that they're exhausted,
昆图斯·卢塔蒂乌斯·卡图卢斯，这让迦太基人完全措手不及。迦太基人，有些人说他们昏昏欲睡。另一些人说他们精疲力竭，
but they just haven't prepared for this crisis, which they must have known was coming. The Carthaginian fleet has been kept at Carthage. The news is brought that the Romans are coming.
但他们只是没有为这场危机做好准备，而他们本该知道危机即将来临。迦太基舰队一直停在迦太基。罗马人即将来袭的消息传来了。
They sail out. The Romans annihilate them. Disappointing. So it's just a total walkover. Total walkover, because basically the traditional situation where it's the Carthaginians who are more proficient has been turned on its head. The Romans have been practicing and practicing and practicing, and it seems that the Carthaginians haven't. Whether, as I say, they're too depressed. Run out of money, exhausted. Run out of money. Yeah, they're just down. And so they lose the commanding general, who inevitably is called Hanno. He goes back, he gets crucified, and effectively the war is now over.
他们出航了。罗马人歼灭了他们。令人失望。所以这简直是一场一边倒的胜利。一边倒的胜利，因为基本上迦太基人更精通海战的传统局面被颠覆了。罗马人一直在练习、练习、再练习，而迦太基人似乎没有。正如我所说，他们要么太沮丧。钱花光了，精疲力竭。钱花光了。是的，他们只是情绪低落。所以他们失去了指挥官，不可避免地，他叫汉诺。他回去后被钉死在十字架上，实际上战争现在结束了。
And Hamilcar, you know, in his mountain hideout, he knows that it's doomed. You know, he can see the kind of the shattered spars of the Carthaginian fleet floating off Drapana. It's all terrible. And so the Carthaginian Senate back in the mother city says to Hamilcar, you should go and negotiate with the Romans. Hamilcar does not want the shame of this to attach to himself. And so he sends the commander of Lilibaeum, a man called Gisco, to go and meet with Catulus. And Lutetius' terms, I mean, they're severe, but they're not utterly crippling. So Carthaginians have to withdraw from Sicily, but not Sardinia. So that's an advance on what they were previously offered. Yeah. They have to return all their prisoners without ransom. They have to guarantee not to
而哈米尔卡，你知道，在他山里的藏身处，他知道大势已去。你知道，他能看到德拉帕纳外漂浮的迦太基舰队的残骸。一切都很糟糕。所以母城的迦太基元老院对哈米尔卡说，你应该去和罗马人谈判。哈米尔卡不想让这种耻辱加在自己身上。于是他派利利巴厄姆的指挥官，一个叫吉斯科的人，去会见卡图卢斯。卢塔蒂乌斯的条件，我的意思是，很严厉，但并非完全无法承受。所以迦太基人必须撤出西西里，但不是撒丁岛。所以这比他们之前被提供的条件有所进步。是的。他们必须归还所有囚犯，不得索要赎金。他们必须保证不
make war on Hero, the king of Syracuse. Oh, he's still around. He's still around. And they have to pay a kind of massive Versailles-type indemnity. Right. So Catulus agrees to this. He goes back. He presents the terms to the popular assemblies in Rome, where the mass of the Roman people say they're not tough enough. So they demand a higher indemnity, which the Carthaginians have no choice but to agree
对叙拉古国王希罗发动战争。哦，他还活着。他还活着。而且他们必须支付一种巨额的凡尔赛式的赔款。没错。所以卡图卢斯同意了。他回去后。他向罗马的人民大会提交了条款，罗马大众说这些条款不够强硬。所以他们要求更高的赔款，迦太基人别无选择，只能同意
to. But Hamilcar is able to get the Romans to agree that neither side will interfere in the internal business of the other power. So in other words, just as the Carthaginians agree not to go to war with Hero in Syracuse, so the Romans are agreeing not to come to the support of any of the Carthaginian subject peoples. And this is very important if the Carthaginians to hold their empire together. And so the treaty is ratified by both sides.
。但哈米尔卡成功让罗马人同意双方互不干涉对方的内部事务。换句话说，正如迦太基人同意不与叙拉古的希罗开战一样，罗马人也同意不向任何迦太基属民提供支持。如果迦太基要维持其帝国，这一点非常重要。于是条约得到了双方的批准。
Hamokar leads his men down from the mountain, down to Drapana, board ships, sail off to Carthage. He leaves Gisgo behind to supervise the withdrawal of all the other mercenaries, not just from Drapana, but from Lilibaea. Meanwhile, Hamilcar has gone back to Carthage. And the reason that he's been so desperate to head back and not to take charge of the withdrawal of the mercenaries from Sicily is because he knows, he understands the massive problem that Carthage is now facing. That the troops in Sicily are mercenaries and will want to be paid, but the treasury is empty.
哈米尔卡带领部下从山上下来，到达德拉帕纳，登上船，驶向迦太基。他把吉斯科留在后面，监督所有其他雇佣兵的撤离，不仅是从德拉帕纳，还有从利利巴厄姆。与此同时，哈米尔卡已经回到了迦太基。他之所以如此急于回去，而不去负责从西西里撤离雇佣兵，是因为他知道，他明白迦太基现在面临的巨大问题。西西里的军队是雇佣兵，会要求支付工资，但国库是空的。
And because of the terms that Hamilcar has just agreed with the Romans, they have to pay this indemnity. There isn't any money to pay the mercenaries. So this is why he's been so keen that Gisco gets all the responsibility for handling it. Hamilcar is a very shrewd politician, very brilliant self-publicist. So he's able to present himself as the guy who carried the fight on to the very end, then did his patriotic duty by getting the best terms that he could, but he doesn't want to be associated with what this surrender actually means. The truth is that the situation with the mercenaries is very, very alarming because the mercenaries arrive in Africa and the Carthaginians have failed to take hostages for their good behavior before they land in Africa.
由于哈米尔卡刚刚与罗马人达成的条款，他们必须支付这笔赔款。没有钱支付雇佣兵。这就是为什么他如此渴望让吉斯科承担处理这件事的所有责任。哈米尔卡是一位非常精明的政治家，非常出色的自我宣传者。所以他能够把自己塑造成战斗到最后的人，然后通过争取到最好的条件尽了爱国义务，但他不想与这次投降的真正含义联系在一起。事实是，雇佣兵的情况非常非常令人担忧，因为雇佣兵抵达非洲时，迦太基人没能在他们登陆非洲之前扣押人质以确保他们的良好行为。
Very foolish. This is very bad because you now have mercenaries who haven't been paid and they are all together in a large camp outside Carthage and they're starting to get restive. So Gisco by now is back in Carthage as well. And because he had been their commander, the Carthaginian Senate thinks, well, we should send him out to negotiate with them. I'm sure they'll be delighted to see their old commander. So Gisco goes out and he's sent with as much treasure as the Carthaginians can rustle up. And he goes out to the camp. Meanwhile, however, in the camp, there are two mercenaries, one of whom, a guy called Spendius, is an escaped slave from Campania
非常愚蠢。这非常糟糕，因为现在你有了一群没有拿到工资的雇佣兵，他们都聚集在迦太基外的一个大营地里，开始变得焦躁不安。所以吉斯科现在也回到了迦太基。因为他曾是他们的指挥官，迦太基元老院认为，嗯，我们应该派他去和他们谈判。我相信他们会很高兴见到他们的老指挥官。所以吉斯科出发了，带着迦太基人能凑到的所有财宝。他去了营地。然而，与此同时，在营地里，有两个雇佣兵，其中一个叫斯彭迪乌斯，是来自坎帕尼亚的逃亡奴隶，
who had taken service as a mercenary. Another is a guy called Matho, who is a Libyan. Do you want to know what Flaubert says about Matho, Tom? Yeah, tell me what Flaubert says about Matho. He introduces him thus thus on the other side of the tables was a libyan of colossal stature with short black curly hair he had retained only his military jacket the brass plates of which were tearing the purple of the couch a necklace of silver moons was tangled in his hairy breast his face was stained with splashes of blood he was leaning on his left elbow with a smile on his large open mouth.
他以雇佣兵的身份服役。另一个叫马托，是个利比亚人。你想知道福楼拜是怎么评价马托的吗，汤姆？是的，告诉我福楼拜是怎么评价马托的。他是这样介绍他的：在桌子的另一边，坐着一个身材魁梧的利比亚人，留着黑色短卷发。他只保留了军用夹克，上面的铜板已经破损，沙发上的紫色织物，一串银月项链缠在他多毛的胸口。他的脸上沾满了血迹。他左肘倚着，大张的嘴上带着微笑。
So that is what Matho is like. That is what Matho is like. He's hairy, he's huge, he's smiling and he's covered in blood. He rips couches, all that kind of thing. So Spendius and Matho have essentially got the mercenaries behind them. They've said, look, let's conquer Carthage and take it all, take it over. They are duly appointed generals of the mercenary force. And so when Gisco comes, they say, let's take him prisoner. So they take him prisoner and they seize all the
这就是马托的样子。这就是马托的样子。他多毛，巨大，微笑着，浑身是血。他撕碎沙发，诸如此类。所以斯彭迪乌斯和马托基本上得到了雇佣兵的支持。他们说，看，让我们征服迦太基，夺取一切，接管它。他们被正式任命为雇佣兵部队的将军。所以当吉斯科来的时候，他们说，把他抓起来。于是他们把他抓起来，夺取了所有
gold that's been sent and they re-mint it. So this is Carthaginian coinage. The mercenaries re-mint it and they're stamping it. And they're kind of saying that they're a kind of proto-state. And there are 20,000 mercenaries. And because of Matho, this giant hairy Libyan, they are able to raise maybe up to kind of 70,000 Libyans from the interior beyond Carthage. So this is almost 100,000 troops. And the Carthaginians don't really have the men to oppose them. They don't have any. Yeah, they don't. I love this.
送来的黄金，并重新铸造了它。所以这是迦太基的货币。雇佣兵重新铸造并盖上了戳。他们有点像是在说他们是一个原始国家。有20000名雇佣兵。因为马托这个巨大的多毛利比亚人，他们能够从迦太基以外的内陆地区召集多达70000名利比亚人。所以这几乎是10万军队。而迦太基人真的没有兵力来对抗他们。他们根本没有。是的，他们没有。我喜欢这个。
I love the mercenary war. I love Salambo, which I did at university. And basically, it's just unbelievably statistic and blood-soaked, isn't it? What follows? Absolutely hideous. And Polybius says that this is, of all wars, the war in which the greatest atrocities and cruelties were practiced. And in part, that is because the
我喜欢雇佣兵战争。我喜欢《萨朗波》，我在大学时读过。基本上，它简直令人难以置信地血腥，不是吗？接下来发生了什么？绝对可怕。波利比阿说，这是所有战争中，最残忍、最暴虐的战争。部分原因是
mercenaries know that by taking this step, if they're defeated, they can expect no mercy. But likewise, Carthage knows that she is fighting for her very survival. So what are you going to do if you're Carthage and you're fighting for your very survival? Obviously, you're going to turn to a Hanno. This is what you do in this situation, despite the fact that as far as I know, from the records, every time a Hanno leads something, they turn out to be terrible. They've never won with a Hanno, Tom. So this guy, he's called Hanno the Great. And this is because he seems to have been the most significant political player in Carthage for the previous two decades.
雇佣兵知道，采取这一步，如果他们战败，他们将得不到任何怜悯。同样，迦太基也知道她是在为生存而战。所以如果你是迦太基，正在为生存而战，你会怎么做？显然，你会求助于汉诺。这就是你在这种情况下会做的，尽管据我所知，根据记录，每次汉诺领导什么，结果都很糟糕。汤姆，他们从来没有在汉诺的领导下赢过。所以这个家伙，他叫“伟大的汉诺”。这是因为他似乎是过去二十年来迦太基最重要的政治人物。
So while Hamilcar is the great military leader, Hanno seems to have been the political commander in chief. So he gets told, go out and defeat these mercenaries. Predictably, he makes a complete hash of it. And so the people say, well, Hanno's hopeless. Let's have Hamilcar. He's the military hero. Let's make him joint commander with Hanno. So he's given a very small army, only about 10,000 men, a few war elephants. But because he's a brilliant general, he's able to go out and win the victories that Hanno had been unable to. And the mercenaries are defeated in a couple of battles. And in the camp, Spendius and Mattho are nervous that this may lead to mass desertions. And so they decide to take a step that will effectively ensure that all the mercenaries are dipping their fingers in blood.
所以当哈米尔卡是伟大的军事领袖时，汉诺似乎是政治总司令。所以他被告知，去击败这些雇佣兵。不出所料，他把事情搞得一团糟。于是人们说，汉诺没救了。让我们请哈米尔卡。他是军事英雄。让我们让他和汉诺共同指挥。所以他得到了一支非常小的军队，只有大约10000人，几头战象。但因为他是一位出色的将军，他能够出去赢得汉诺无法赢得的胜利。雇佣兵在几场战斗中被击败。在营地里，斯彭迪乌斯和马托担心这会导致大规模逃兵。于是他们决定采取一步行动，确保所有雇佣兵都沾满鲜血。
So what they do, contrary to all the laws of war, is that they put Gisco and the other Carthaginian members of the embassy to death and they do it horribly. So what they do, they cut the hands off of Gisco and the other Carthaginians. They castrate them. And we haven't had some genital mutilation for a while. And they then break their legs. They throw them into a pit, and they then bury them alive. And the leaders of the mercenaries, so Spendius and Matho, then say that this is how all Carthaginian prisons of war will be treated. So they really are making it impossible now to have any settlement. It is absolutely a war to the death. And so Hamilcar reciprocates. If he captures any of the mercenaries, he has them trampled to death by elephants.
所以他们所做的，违反了所有战争法，就是将吉斯科和其他迦太基使团成员处死，而且手段极其残忍。他们砍掉了吉斯科和其他迦太基人的手。阉割了他们。我们已经有一段时间没有提到生殖器残割了。然后他们打断了他们的腿。把他们扔进坑里，然后活埋了他们。雇佣兵的领袖，斯彭迪乌斯和马托，然后说这就是所有迦太基战俘的下场。所以他们现在真的让任何和解都变得不可能了。这绝对是一场你死我活的战争。于是哈米尔卡以牙还牙。如果他俘虏了任何雇佣兵，他就让他们被大象踩死。
Hanno is still on the scene, but general acceptance is that he's so rubbish that in this war to the death, they need Hamilcar. And so the troops, all the Carthaginian troops vote for Hamilcar to be sole general. And this is obviously good because it means that the guy best qualified to win the war now has sole command. And there are also two other positives. And one is that help and reinforcements arrive from Carthage's old enemy, Syracuse. And the reason for this probably is that Hero, who is still in situ, he's nervous about the Romans being too powerful.
汉诺仍然在场，但普遍的共识是他太垃圾了，在这场你死我活的战争中，他们需要哈米尔卡。于是部队，所有的迦太基部队投票支持哈米尔卡担任唯一将军。这显然是好事，因为这意味着最有资格赢得战争的人现在拥有了唯一指挥权。还有两个积极因素。一是来自迦太基的老敌人叙拉古的援助和增援。这背后的原因可能是希罗，他仍然在位，他担心罗马人太强大了。
So he wants Carthage to survive. So it will be a counterweight to the Romans. But help also comes from Rome. So they release all the prisoners, Carthaginian prisoners, that they'd been keeping without demanding a ransom. And they issue an absolutely strict ban that no one in Italy is allowed to help the mercenaries. And again, you might think, well, why are they doing this to their old enemy? And the reason obviously is because they want Carthage to survive so that it can pay the indemnity. So it's a little bit as if the Allies had intervened to help the Weimar Republic
所以他希望迦太基生存下去。这样它就能成为对抗罗马人的制衡力量。但援助也来自罗马。他们释放了所有他们一直关押的迦太基囚犯，没有要求赎金。并且他们发布了绝对严格的禁令，禁止意大利任何人帮助雇佣兵。同样，你可能会想，好吧，他们为什么要对他们的老敌人这样做？原因显然是因为他们希望迦太基生存下去，这样它才能支付赔款。所以这有点像盟军干预帮助魏玛共和国
during the German revolution or something. Yes, I think that's exactly the analogy. So things are starting to improve for Carthage. And then in 238, so a couple of years after the outbreak of the revolt, the great decisive moment comes when Hamilcar successfully traps a large chunk of the mercenary army in a narrow pass called the Saw. So it's called the Battle of the Saw. Yeah, Flaubert calls it the Defile of the Axe, which I think sounds better than the Saw. Yeah, Defile of the Axe is better, I agree. Yeah. Anyway, sorry, that's just by the by. Well, let's call it the Defile of the Axe. And Hamilcar blockades them,
在德国革命期间或其他什么。是的，我认为这正是那个类比。所以迦太基的情况开始好转。然后在公元前238年，也就是起义爆发几年后，伟大的决定性时刻到来了，哈米尔卡成功地将一大批雇佣兵军队困在了一个叫“锯子”的狭窄山口。所以它被称为“锯子之战”。是的，福楼拜称之为“斧头峡谷”，我觉得这听起来比“锯子”好。是的，斧头峡谷更好，我同意。是的。总之，抱歉，那只是顺便一提。好吧，我们叫它斧头峡谷。哈米尔卡封锁了他们，
and there's none of this Samnite thing of allowing them to go through a yoke or anything like that. Hamilcar, basically, he starves them out. And so the mercenaries, they kill their prisoners, they kill their slaves, they eat them. And then once they've done that, they recognise that they've got no choice but to negotiate. And so Spendius had been in charge of this. Matho is with the other army. So Spendius and nine other of the mercenaries go out to treat with Hamilcar. And Hamilcar offers them what seemed to be very mild terms. He says, yeah, fine, you can go. The whole army can go, but you will need to leave me with 10 hostages. And Spendius and his nine colleagues agree. And of course, the 10 hostages that Hamilcar chooses is Spendius and his nine colleagues agree. And of course, the 10 hostages that Hamilcar chooses
没有萨姆尼特人那种允许他们穿过轭口之类的东西。哈米尔卡基本上把他们饿死了。于是雇佣兵们杀死了他们的囚犯，杀死了他们的奴隶，吃掉了他们。一旦他们这样做了，他们意识到别无选择，只能谈判。所以斯彭迪乌斯一直负责这件事。马托在另一支军队里。所以斯彭迪乌斯和其他九名雇佣兵出去与哈米尔卡谈判。哈米尔卡给了他们看起来非常温和的条件。他说，好吧，没问题，你们可以走。整支军队都可以走，但你们需要留下10个人质。斯彭迪乌斯和他的九个同事同意了。当然，哈米尔卡选择的10个人质是斯彭迪乌斯和他的九个同事同意了。当然，哈米尔卡选择的10个人质
is Spendius and the other nine negotiators. Very canny. Yes. And so he then seizes them, keeps them, fetters them up, and then slaughters the entire army. Oh, he breaks his word. He does break his word because he says that the murderers of Gisgo were beyond the pale. That's fair, I think, Tom. They behaved very poorly to Gisgo. And to be honest, do you have to keep your word to a mercenary anyway? Yeah.
是斯彭迪乌斯和其他九名谈判代表。非常精明。是的。于是他抓住了他们，扣留了他们，给他们戴上镣铐，然后屠杀了整支军队。哦，他食言了。他确实食言了，因为他说杀害吉斯科的凶手罪不可赦。我认为这很公平，汤姆。他们对吉斯科的行为非常恶劣。老实说，你真的需要对雇佣兵守信用吗？是的。
Well, so now the war reaches its, can I say, hideous climax, don't I? Oh, we love a hideous climax. A hideous climax. So Hamilcar and his deputy are inevitably called Hannibal. But he's not Hannibal,
好吧，现在战争达到了，我可以这么说吗，可怕的高潮，不是吗？哦，我们喜欢可怕的高潮。一个可怕的高潮。所以哈米尔卡和他的副手不可避免地被称为汉尼拔。但他不是汉尼拔，
to be clear. This is not the famous Hannibal who we'll be coming to shortly. Hamilcar and his deputy are called Hannibal. They march on the remaining army, which is led by Matho, the Libyan, big hairy Libyan. And they arrive outside Matho's camp and they put up 10 crosses and they nail Spendius and the other nine ambassadors to the crosses and they kind of leave them there. And Mattho is so outraged, so appalled, so humiliated that he summons his men and they ambush Hannibal's force and they capture Hannibal and they torture him at the foot of Spendius's cross. And they then take down the body of Spendius and they nail Hannibal alive to the
要明确一点。这不是我们很快就会提到的那个著名的汉尼拔。哈米尔卡和他的副手被称为汉尼拔。他们向剩下的军队进军，那支军队由利比亚人马托领导，那个巨大的多毛利比亚人。他们到达马托的营地外，竖起了10个十字架，把斯彭迪乌斯和其他九名大使钉在十字架上，把他们留在那儿。马托感到如此愤怒，如此震惊，如此羞辱，以至于他召集了他的部下，他们伏击了汉尼拔的部队，俘虏了汉尼拔，并在斯彭迪乌斯的十字架下折磨他。然后他们取下斯彭迪乌斯的尸体，把汉尼拔活活钉在
cross. And they take 30 high-ranking Carthaginian prisoners and they sacrifice them at the foot of the cross as a kind of, you know, a sacrifice to the spirit of Spendius. And Hamilcar in the face of this has to beat a retreat, but it's fine. He hasn't suffered any major defeat and he patches things up with Hanno and the two of them advance out again. And in the autumn of 238, they meet with the surviving mercenaries and they win an absolutely crushing victory. Most of the mercenaries are wiped out. The survivors are all crucified and Matho is taken prisoner. So Matho has survived, but his fate is uh very exciting isn't it yes so he is taken to carthage and kept in prison for a year and then in the following year 237 he is made to walk through the streets of carthage in a kind of parody of the triumphal procession that
十字架上。他们抓了30名高级迦太基囚犯，在十字架下献祭他们，作为一种，你知道，对斯彭迪乌斯灵魂的祭品。面对这种情况，哈米尔卡不得不撤退，但这没关系。他没有遭受任何重大失败，他与汉诺修补了关系，两人再次出击。在公元前238年秋天，他们遇到了幸存的雇佣兵，并赢得了绝对压倒性的胜利。大多数雇佣兵被消灭了。幸存者都被钉死在十字架上，马托被俘。所以马托幸存了下来，但他的命运非常令人兴奋，不是吗？是的，所以他被带到迦太基，关在监狱里一年，然后在第二年，公元前237年，他被迫走过迦太基的街道，作为一种凯旋游行的模仿，
he would have enjoyed had he managed to enter the great city and dominic i'm sure you'll remember it from reading salambo there's a horrible horrible account of it it's the kind of we love a hideous climax it's the hideous climax of salambo and in flober's version of it it's decreed that he can walk through the streets without an escort but with his arms tied behind his back and the crowds are not allowed to put out his eyes because Matho has to be able to see what is being done to him. And they're not allowed to cripple him because he has to carry on walking. And they're not allowed to inflict anything that would kill him. Anything else, they can do what they want to do. And so this is Flaubert's description of what happens. The crowds discharged little drops of boiling oil through tubes at him. They strewed pieces of broken glass beneath his feet.
如果他成功进入这座伟大的城市，他本可以享受那种游行。多米尼克，我相信你从阅读《萨朗波》中还记得，那里有极其可怕的描述。这是一种我们喜欢可怕高潮的类型，这是《萨朗波》可怕的高潮。在福楼拜的版本中，规定他可以在没有护送的情况下走过街道，但双手被绑在背后。人群不允许挖出他的眼睛，因为马托必须能够看到对他所做的一切。他们不允许让他残废，因为他必须继续走。他们不允许施加任何会杀死他的东西。除此之外，他们可以做任何他们想做的事。这就是福楼拜对所发生事情的描述。人群通过管子向他喷洒小滴沸油。他们在他的脚下撒上碎玻璃。
Still he walked on. The slaves of the council struck him with their whips of hippopotamus leather so furiously and long that the fringes of their tunics were drenched with sweat. Matho appeared insensible. Suddenly he started off and began to run at random, making a noise with his lips like one shivering with severe cold. That's not even the worst bit, Tom. Do you want to come to the worst bit?
他仍然继续走。元老院的奴隶用河马皮鞭疯狂地抽打他，时间太长，以至于他们束腰外衣的边缘都被汗水浸透了。马托似乎毫无知觉。突然他冲了出去，开始乱跑，嘴唇发出像因严寒而颤抖的人那样的声音。那甚至不是最糟糕的部分，汤姆。你想听最糟糕的部分吗？
Well, I mean, there's so many bits. Because Flobo, as we said in the first episode, he really kind of goes to town on this, doesn't he? A child rent his ear. A young girl hiding the point of a spindle in her sleeve spit his cheek. They tore handfuls of hair from him. He was very hairy and strips of flesh.
好吧，我的意思是，有太多部分了。因为福楼拜，正如我们在第一集所说，他真的在这方面大做文章，不是吗？一个孩子撕裂了他的耳朵。一个年轻女孩把纺锤尖藏在袖子里刺他的脸颊。他们从他身上扯下一把把头发。他非常多毛，还有肉条。
Others smeared his face with sponges steeped in filth and fastened upon sticks. And then it just kind of goes on and on of flesh. Others smeared his face with sponges steeped in filth and fastened upon sticks. And then it just kind of goes on and on and on. And at the end, Flaubert says at one point, he had no appearance of humanity left. He was a long, perfectly red shape. I mean, by the standards of 1860s kind of Victorian novels. It's not Man of Bowery, is it?
其他人用浸满污秽并固定在棍子上的海绵涂抹他的脸。然后它就一直持续下去，肉条。其他人用浸满污秽并固定在棍子上的海绵涂抹他的脸。然后它就一直持续下去，一直持续下去。最后，福楼拜在某一点说，他已经没有任何人性了。他是一个长长的、完全红色的形状。我的意思是，按照1860年代维多利亚时代小说的标准。这不是《鲍厄里的男人》，对吧？
No, no. No, I mean, it's not Dickens even. So this takes us back to where we began with Flaubert's kind of imagining of Carthage. And of course, we opened the series, Dominic, with Flaubert imagining a sacrifice to Moloch, the Carthaginian elite sacrificing their children in this great blazing furnace, which you do at moments of particular peril because your child, of course, is the most precious thing that you have. And in that account, Hamilcar is pressured by the council to sacrifice his eldest son, who of course had been born while Hamilcar was in Sicily. And this boy was given the
不，不。不，我的意思是，甚至不是狄更斯。所以这把我们带回了我们开始的地方，福楼拜对迦太基的想象。当然，多米尼克，我们以福楼拜想象对摩洛克的祭祀开始了本系列，迦太基精英在巨大的燃烧炉中牺牲他们的孩子，你在特别危险的时刻这样做，因为你的孩子当然是你拥有的最珍贵的东西。在那段描述中，哈米尔卡受到元老院的压力，要求牺牲他的长子，那个当然是在哈米尔卡在西西里时出生的孩子。这个男孩被取名为
name of Hannibal. So Hannibal Barker. And it's an echo of a scene that almost certainly did happen. And it didn't involve Moloch and it didn't involve human sacrifice, but it did involve sacrifice before the greatest of the gods of Carthage, which was Balhamon. And Hamilcar Barca, he is now the greatest man in Carthage. He has won this great victory over the mercenaries. He was the last man standing against the Romans in Sicily. And yet at the same time, he has been powerless to oppose the Romans who were behaving very, very badly. Even though the Romans did not intervene in the mercenary war, they take advantage of Carthage's distraction to seize Sardinia against the terms of the peace treaty. And when the Carthaginians complain,
汉尼拔。所以汉尼拔·巴卡。这是几乎肯定发生过的一幕的回响。它不涉及摩洛克，也不涉及活人祭祀，但它确实涉及在迦太基最伟大的神巴尔哈蒙面前的祭祀。哈米尔卡·巴卡，他现在是迦太基最伟大的人。他赢得了对雇佣兵的这场伟大胜利。他是西西里对抗罗马人的最后一人。然而与此同时，他无力对抗那些行为非常非常恶劣的罗马人。尽管罗马人没有干预雇佣兵战争，但他们利用迦太基的分心，违反和平条约的条款夺取了撒丁岛。当迦太基人抱怨时，
the Romans threaten them with war. So it's like that phrase that the Gauls had said to the Romans when they captured Rome and extorted lots of treasure out of them, woe to the defeated. And so the Carthaginians have no option but to suck it up. But obviously they feel incredible resentment. And probably there's no one who feels greater resentment than Hamilcar, this great patriotic figure, greatest military leader, the man who dreams of seeing his city restored to her former position as undisputed mistress of the West. And so he knows that he needs to find some way with Sicily off limits, with Sardinia lost to restore Carthage's fortunes and above all finances. And so he looks to Spain because Spain is a place so rich in silver that
罗马人威胁要对他们开战。所以这就像高卢人在占领罗马并勒索大量财宝时对罗马人说的那句话，失败者有祸了。所以迦太基人别无选择，只能忍气吞声。但显然他们感到难以置信的怨恨。可能没有人比哈米尔卡感到更大的怨恨，这位伟大的爱国人物，最伟大的军事领袖，梦想着看到他的城市恢复其作为无可争议的西方女主人地位的人。所以他知道他需要找到某种方法，在西西里被禁止、撒丁岛丢失的情况下，恢复迦太基的财富，最重要的是财政。所以他看向西班牙，因为西班牙是一个盛产白银的地方，
it is said when there are forest fires on the high slopes of the mountains, liquid silver runs in torrents down the side of the hill. And so he decides that this is where he's going to go. He's going to carve out a new empire. He sets out for there in 237. But before he leaves, as I say, he goes to offer sacrifice to Balhamon. And he takes with him his eldest son, this little boy, Hannibal, who by now is about nine years old. And he offers sacrifice and the omens prove favorable. Balhamon approves of Hamilcar's expedition to Spain. And this then done, Hamilcar orders everyone to withdraw except for his young boy, Hannibal. And he calls Hannibal, come and stand by me. And then he says, would you like to come with me to Spain?
据说当高山斜坡上发生森林火灾时，液态银会像洪流一样顺着山坡流下。所以他决定这就是他要去的地方。他要开辟一个新的帝国。他在公元前237年出发前往那里。但在他离开之前，正如我所说，他去向巴尔哈蒙献祭。他带着他的长子，这个小男孩汉尼拔，当时大约九岁。他献祭，预兆证明是吉祥的。巴尔哈蒙批准了哈米尔卡的西班牙远征。这完成后，哈米尔卡命令所有人撤退，只留下他的小男孩汉尼拔。他叫汉尼拔，过来站在我身边。然后他说，你想和我一起去西班牙吗？
And Hannibal's eyes light up and he says, yes, I would love to come to Spain. you like to come with me to spain and hannibal's eyes light up and he says yes i i would love to come to spain i want to be with you and hamilcar nods and then he tells his son lay your hand on the carcass of the sacrificial victim and swear this oath that you will never bear goodwill to the romans and the little boy swears it but he will never bear goodwill to the Romans. And the little boy swears it, but he will never bear goodwill to the Romans. And this boy, nine-year-old son of Hamilcar, Hannibal Barca, after Hamilcar goes on to die in Spain, having carved out the great empire that he'd wanted to carve out, Hannibal will succeed to its rule. And in due course, he will launch an invasion of Italy itself, leading war elephants over the Alps and bringing the Romans to a succession of terrible defeats and bringing Rome itself
汉尼拔眼睛一亮，说，是的，我很想去西班牙。你想和我一起去西班牙吗，汉尼拔眼睛一亮，说，是的，我很想去西班牙，我想和你在一起。哈米尔卡点点头，然后他告诉他的儿子，把你的手放在祭品的尸体上，发誓这个誓言，你永远不会对罗马人怀有善意。小男孩发誓了，但他永远不会对罗马人怀有善意。小男孩发誓了，但他永远不会对罗马人怀有善意。这个男孩，哈米尔卡九岁的儿子，汉尼拔·巴卡，在哈米尔卡在西班牙去世后，开辟了他想要开辟的伟大帝国，汉尼拔将继承其统治。在适当的时候，他将发动对意大利本身的入侵，带领战象翻越阿尔卑斯山，给罗马人带来一系列可怕的失败，并将罗马本身
to the very brink of utter disaster. Hannibal will be remembered by the Romans for all time as the greatest of all their enemies. And Dominic, next year maybe, we will continue the story of Carthage and we will look at the rise to greatness of Hannibal. We will indeed. What a wonderful series, Tom, and what an amazing incentive for people to carry on listening to the rest of history.
带到彻底灾难的边缘。汉尼拔将被罗马人永远铭记为他们所有敌人中最伟大的一个。多米尼克，明年也许，我们将继续迦太基的故事，我们将看看汉尼拔走向伟大的历程。我们确实会。多么精彩的系列，汤姆，对于人们继续收听历史的其余部分来说，这是多么惊人的激励。
Knowing that one day when they least expect it, Hannibal will return. So that was a fantastic, a blood-drenched tour de force. Everything that we wanted from a history of Carthage. Tom, thank you very much. That was absolutely wonderful. So next week, we have a complete change of tone. We will be returning with a history of chocolate from its Mesoamerican origins
知道有一天当他们最意想不到的时候，汉尼拔会回来。所以那是一次精彩的、血腥的杰作。我们从迦太基历史中想要的一切。汤姆，非常感谢你。那绝对太棒了。所以下周，我们将完全改变基调。我们将带着巧克力从其中美洲起源的历史回归
to its glory days in Victorian Birmingham. And then the episode that I think many people have been waiting for, for years, frankly, that you'll only get on The Rest is History. And that is, of course, history's greatest monkeys. so we will see you for those episodes next week bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
到它在维多利亚时代伯明翰的辉煌岁月。然后是我想很多人已经等了几年的一集，坦率地说，你只能在《历史的其余部分》中听到。那就是，当然，历史上最伟大的猴子。所以我们下周会在那些剧集中见到你们，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。